hello everybody and welcome to part 3 if
let's play pan number of the Black
Plague as you all know we left off with
me kicking the ass of a monster there
wasn't even a little bit scary oh this
again wait what I bet I've been here I
did this I know this I know I did that
am I going crazy
salvation this what what the hell I was
just here oh no that was the first
hallway I was in what was that
why did what I'm so confused
what the hell just happened did I what
Oh No Oh No
Oh No what why oh man that makes no
sense
what what happened huh I am how even
might even my thing is still here this
is all I did this I did this
guys you saw I did I still the can
there's my barrel what the hell happened
how did I go in a circle I've never been
that way before I'm so confused
I went in that room is that the room I
was in oh that's that's my first I'll
get out of here
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah oh
I got a syringe why do I do what I do
that's a Ramos first in
oh there's something in this room yeah
bring it on oh you can't get me Oh how'd
you get me okay this is thinking outside
the box
maybe if I like use a syringe get the
blood from this guy
perfectly normal come on get straight
get straightened out there we go boink
boink boink ah yeah that was it now Oh
trusted blood Oh trusted blood so smart
oh so smart boy fast
I'm the best
the best
yeah yeah you were talking to it
whatever oh yeah I'll start reading
those what are you guys here outside
freedom see no no maybe it's from a
light bulb that wouldn't be natural
would it be broken
oh um yep it sure is we tell you you're
too late no I'm not sorry no you're not
blah blah blah still good flow all my
chest or the trouble eight three oh man
Howard my data or John's debt not my dad
this looks cool looks so cool another
monster whatever barrel a crap or oil
I'm a prefer to be oil dump out the
barrel nothing in their boxes right here
it's an under the middle op batters boss
so smart
everywhere ah get out there Oh so top
the top lights broken any lights which
no UV lighting on the wall nope nope no
didn't seem like it all right we got a
fuse box can I use anything
whatever need batteries why don't I have
a flashlight yet stay up pop can in
there wait right unless you're not as
condescending as you were before
Oh No you're just as condescending
no not a flare ah this is the first time
I've ever used one of these so enjoy it
enjoy it everybody oh it's gasoline
dredge with gasoline
oh yeah let me light it on fire with my
flare
Oh what can I do it this Oh sparks oh
yeah make the sparks yeah light it up
knot it up oh yeah so smart okay now
what I do with the flaming Beryl
Oh put it out pause and fire I'll put it
out oh yeah the shaders are deathlike
better
oh man look at that all the graphics I'm
not even being concise crap - way better
all right so I got a flaming barrel what
Oh how did I miss it
Wow oh there we go
oh yeah oh yeah oh so great box of
Wheaties yeah hired ate my Wheaties this
morning that's why I'm so free ha ha hey
pots and pans falling down at the boring
give it catch up so much ketchup these
guys in ketchup okay Oh a head nope
a severed head nope
come on open up
Josh can get offered head severed head
no regular old trash I'll get to the
severed heads later in the game huh
nothing
hold up book exciting not 200 high-tech
oh yeah I got CD research fascinating
analysis Philip huh
[Music]
Howard oh this guy's named Phillip I'm
in calling him John I'm screwed he's
John I don't care what you say he's John
alright door controller not be Exeter's
that sounds about right
and her password but thanks ah yeah
right
stupid groin ah stupid girl fat [ __ ]
alright low stick it is not nearly as
effective in the last two games last
light finally all right oh cool sure Oh
a password in here huh bet
okay yeah I know all this I know my
history lalalala okay copied it all Wow
okay what do we got Oh Copenhagen
dr. Jake Peters Howard lift grass that
Conn asked
stupid list frisk turn gate
I remember that word from before no
pastor that I could tell
safety 366 nothing nothing abuse
absolutely dick
diddly ah come on
what is no no not a single door in this
entire place where all the CD CD this
computer would I guess it does have a CD
okay
yes welcome to Shelton Research Station
Greenland shelter is an almost entirely
self-sufficient installation is not in
the 70s to further serve the purpose of
elevated caste in their pursuit and
defense of ancient knowledge there's a
new member of the facility there are
some basic rules you should be aware of
in order to be useful to the archaic
unuseful shelter provides living
facilities including a mess hall
gymnasium and medical bay in addition to
the stipulated array of laboratories
chemical and biological workstations
excavation equipment security please use
the floor at your leisure but expect to
be assigned to the letter with a
moment's notice
second due to the nature of our work
here should you feel in any way ill
little lightheaded
or otherwise mentally incapacitated do
not report to the medical facility
that's bad news
passing yourself securely to whatever
solid object we have available attempt
to seal off the doors and await ritual
trained professionals phenomenal
University scenario be prepared to
swallow your personal cyanide capsule
will be issued sanso
the archaic hates to lose its treasured
staff but it may be for the good of the
operation oh you know you will enjoy
your work with us yeah 14 oh yeah
one one six seven that's oh right on the
money
oh so smart oh god okay anyway my
smartness is gonna have to wait because
I have to pause here thank you so much
for watching and I will see you guys in
part four of let's play pan number the
Black Plague
bye bye